otra vez gazas dentro de una nueva
espiral de violencia con múltiples
bombardeos de israel y contraataques con
cohetes lanzados en esta ocasión por la
yihad islámica palestina
sobre las cuatro y media de la tarde el
ejército israelí inició la franja su
operación despertar del alba alegando un
ataque que previniera cualquier acción
de la yihad pues el lunes israel capturó
a su líder en cisjordania bastante
shading en estos primeros bombardeos las
fuerzas israelíes mataron a taysir al
yabari comandante del grupo en el centro
y norte de gaza desde el año 2019 pero
además aunque israel afirma que sus
ataques son objetivos terroristas estos
están en zonas pobladas y han causado la
muerte de civiles palestinos entre ellos
la de una niña de 5 años tras esto la
jihad islámica respondió con lanzamiento
de cohetes que mantienen en alerta a
ciudades del sur y centro de israel si
bien la mayoría han sido interceptados
por la cúpula de hierro israelí aún no
está claro si jamás se sumará a esta
escalada o si egipto como mediador
logrará una tregua pero el primer
ministro interino israelí la isla [__]
dijo que la operación el tiempo que sea
necesario y que no han terminado
mientras las facciones palestinas
advirtieron de que los ataques no
quedarán impunes por ahora israel
convocó a 25 mil reservistas que
apoyarían una prolongación de estos
ataques y en ciudades como ramala o
yenín se han registrado marchas
palestinas en apoyo de la yihad islámica
el hecho de que la isla pita antes de
las elecciones de noviembre pueda
mostrarse como un líder de perfil duro
sobrevuela esta violencia que en última
instancia afecta a más de 2 millones de
civiles en gaza que aún no se han
recuperado de los bombardeos israelí
desde 2021 y que sufre desde hace días
cortes eléctricos de más de 10 horas